uh but the stanford kids i found
maybe not as like uh
like um confident in that way
but a little bit more uh
creative on the uh startup side is that
fair to say when people look at the two
programs because they are competitive
do they do they draw two different types
of people you know i mean i think they
do draw two types of people to an extent
but the type of ideas well i think
people who
look if you want to be a real like if
you if you're if you're
passionate about something you've got
this idea and you're going to start this
company
i don't know that you're necessarily
initially go to either school would you
i mean
you know i think the people who come to
hbs
and really fall in love with
entrepreneurship and realize hey you
know i've got all these skills i've got
all these assets i can really do this
i mean they've got all of these
wonderful experiences
backgrounds that they then kind of flip
into
doing a startup and it and it does i
mean i think that
increasingly we're seeing some really
creative ideas
are the majority of folks going to hbs
looking to start a company or looking to
become senior leadership at
established companies go into banking
what percentage do you think i mean i
think the larger percentage is probably
the latter that there's more that are
looking to go into senior management
positions
gm rolls that sort of thing but over the
course of their careers i mean some of
them start out
wanting that and doing that for a couple
of years realize that they want to start
something on their own and so we see
that
you know 90 of of people who um
end up starting a company are ones that
have worked in some other industry first
and then decide that they want to do
that later on
what percentage of the classes ballpark
are non-american international students
because i just spoke at stanford uh
where they did a case study on me
actually
and i think two-thirds were not
from america it was amazing the number
of
countries in the room yeah i mean i
don't know the exact percentage but we
have this
um in each section there's a flag day
and it's this this amazing sort of night
where you
all of the people will give a little
presentation about the country that
they're from
or you know they're families and
and you know the room is filled with
different flags so i would say like 50
or 60 different flags so it's pretty
yeah
national origin of american students but
international students who
i think both i think both so people who
some that were born in those countries
and you know so yeah any interesting
countries like is
anybody from north korea russia
azerbaijan
um i just wanted to be able to say that
i tried existed
yeah we've got a lot of chinese students
that's fascinating yeah it's gotta be
really interesting to have chinese
students
at hbs yeah we've got students in the
climate
yeah for sure the u.s and china is so
weird
weird yeah you know huawei
yeah um intellectual property theft
authoritarianism uh
the nba criticism of china yeah yeah
it's a very
we're so dependent on each other
yet so different yeah but we've got so
many different cultures and you know at
the same time that we've got
palestinians and israelis and you know
there's all sorts of
but i mean it's it works it works
there's like there's really this
this climate where it's you know you're
you're
you're in these sections together and
you're together all day
and you're really learning from each
other so um
it somehow works yeah you got to come
visit yeah i mean i go out when i get
i get invited out every couple years and
i and i do a talk or i interview
somebody last time i was already
interviewed at
moth on stage and he
i mean about five minutes in he lost
like five or six people who just left
and discussed who
because he was like listen you guys are
wasting your money here blah blah blah
he just like went crazy
he's like you guys should put the 250
into whatever